are the thousands of people leaving
their countries and arriving by land and
sea in Europe refugees or migrants
according to the UN refugee agency there
is a clear difference a migrant is
someone who chooses to move to improve
their lives in some way like to find
work but a refugee is someone who is
fleeing arms conflict or persecution and
cannot safely return home while refugees
are protected under international law
and have the right to asylum
migrants must go through the usual
immigration procedures the current
influx of people to Europe includes both
refugees and migrants but the vast
majority are refugees seeking safety